Rain didn't deter Pope Francis' faithful lining up before dawn...
...to catch a glimpse of him on Sunday.
Speaking at Nagasaki's Atomic Bomb Hypocenter Park,...
...ground zero of the bomb dropped during World War II...
...that killed 27,000 people, the pontiff sent a strong message to world leaders.
I ask political leaders not to forget these weapons...
...cannot protect us from current threats to national and international security.
He also called for the bombings of Hiroshima and Nagasaki...
...to be honored as a living memory as opposed to a quote, "relic of the past."
Pope Francis then went on to say holy mass at Nagasaki Stadium...
..with 30,000 worshipers turning out to hear his prayers.